اه يما اه يما
يما
شب والله احنا كنا لسه عمالنا بنحط حالنا
ننام فجاه كل شي ه فوق رؤسنا الله يستر ما
يفجعنا في حد الحمد لله على مصابنا شايفك
شايل شهيد وطفله هذ بنت بنتي ولسه في
شهداء ثانيين بس بعدين الان ما بدنا نحكي
على الاعلام كلكم مدنيين اه كلنا مدنيين
والله العظيم كلنا مدنيين الحمد لله وبس
ما بعرف ايش السبب الحمد لله احنا طالعين
من بيتنا في نصرات في المنطقه اللي مش
يعني خطره وقلنا نروح على الدير اكثر
امانا للاسف للاسف في صبق انظر شي ولا شي
عدو ظالم مجرم عدو مجرم لكن الا الله
سبحانه وتعالى وربنا يخلفنا في مصيبتنا
خيرا منه وربنا يصبر ابوها وامها اذا امها
ان شاء الله تطلع يا رب امها لسه تحت
الانقاض طفله انا شايف صغير كت قد ايه
عمرها طفله تسع شهور تسع شهور اجمل حفيده
نا والله مش لانها هي الان
شهيده يوم لسه اول يوم بقعد انا
بطعميه لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله جايين
دير البلح مشان امنه عشانها امنه
ياار يا ار يا رب صبنا صبنا يا
رب يا رب صبرنا يا
رب